within minutes of early morning air raid
sirens throughout the city russian
missiles hit targets near la vie
international airport
shattering once again the sense of
relative safety here in the west of
ukraine air raid warning system worked
i'm grateful to the armed forces as they
reacted some missiles which were
launched from the black sea area were
intercepted four missiles hit an
aircraft repair plant as you already
know there have been some attacks in
this part of the country
a training camp in yavariv last week and
a military post at an airfield near
lutsk
but the friday morning airport strike is
the closest the war has come to the city
of la vie so far as you see behind me
smoke is still rising
from the area that was hit we've been
stopped from going any further any
closer to the areas that were hit by
these strikes police have pushed us back
twice we've tried to go over the bridge
but we've been sent back to this area
here so we can't get a clear view of
what's happening but the smoke that
continues to billow over the skies over
the city certainly tells you that
something definitely was hit and is
still on fire
in the eastern city of kharkiv a college
building was shelled killing one person
injuring 11 and trapping another in the
rubble
the city is home to one of the largest
markets in eastern europe and it remains
on fire sparked by shelling on thursday
another shelling in kramatorsk killed
two and injured six
and the capital also attacked the mayor
of key visited a nursery and school he
says was targeted by russian rockets
killing one child and wounding 23. this
is genocide
of the ukrainian population
you have to act now
stop passively observing and stop doing
business with russia
do it now
attacking mostly civilian targets is
proof ukrainian officials say that
russia is choosing not to fight
ukrainian troops instead hitting the
countries most vulnerable
enemies strike against the city of lev
is another proof that it does not fight
ukrainian troops it fights population
children women refugees there is nothing
sacred for them
zayn bus ravi al-jazeera level